Hello to all the viewers. Welcome back
to this episode of What's Up, Prof?
Hello Walter.
Nice to see you again. Yes, you too.
Nice to see you back in your your
checkers. You're smart today. Yes, and
you also look very smart today again.
Thank you. Thank you for joining us. How
was your week?
It was hectic. I can't stand this
lockdown anymore. It's too busy.
Yeah, it's we we are busy.
Um
Let's get to right into it. Let's open
up with a word of prayer.
I'll pray. Okay.
You'll pray? Excellent.
Our heavenly Father, thank you very much
for
bringing us together again. We ask that
the blessing be upon this discussion,
and we also ask that you bless the
viewers and
that the Holy Spirit will enlighten us
with everything. In Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
What have we got today?
Well, I thought maybe we can talk a
little about
the pillars of Adventism.
Seeing that we've discussed in previous
episodes
the spirit of prophecy and the Sabbath,
but there's other other pillars also
that the Seventh-day Adventist Church
stands upon.
And there's a lot of opposition
and misinformation about Seventh-day
Adventists. And there's also
ex-Seventh-day Adventists that make
videos against Seventh-day Adventism.
And maybe you can just elaborate a
little bit for us on what these people
say. Why
do they have some truth in what they
say?
Yeah, this is a this is a a major thing.
There are, as you say,
web pages which
which try to
discredit what Adventism stands for.
And it always boils down to the same
basic things.
And I I do not doubt the sincerity of
these people.
And they feel they must enlighten the
world,
but
they have serious misconceptions.
Now, one of the big things, of course,
is the sanctuary.
Uh the disappointment of 1844,
the investigative judgment,
and the perceived perfectionism
when it comes to the law.
And then, of course, they love to quote
Ellen G. White on these issues
and say, "Now, look here. This is what
she says."
And it is very easy to do that, by the
way.
And the issue of perfectionism is a is a
major.
And the issue of perfectionism has been
a major throughout history.
And we should not forget that.
Uh if the devil can use his tool
to drive people into a self-sustaining
religion, he will do that. Yes. Our
religion is based on Christ.
And our salvation is based on Christ.
And as soon as we bring in an element of
self in our salvation,
then we get into trouble.
But there's no doubt that Christ
requires
obedience. If you love me,
you will keep my commandments. He who
says he loves me and keeps not my
commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in him. I have not come to abolish
the law.
And then he says not one jot or one
tittle by any means depart from the law,
disappear from the law.
Nothing, not one jot or one tittle.
So,
all of these verses tell us that
obedience is a prerequisite.
Now, am I saved through my obedience?
No.
But am I saved without obedience?
No. No. So, how do we get the right
balance?
And I'm always stunned when I when I see
how these people quote
Ellen G. White. This is what they talk
about and all of these issues. Let's
just have a look at what the pillars of
Adventism are that sets this
denomination apart from all others.
And you know, that's a good exercise.
that was a good starting point.
Okay. So, I I have a slide here, and it
says, "After the great disappointment."
Now, we can stop right there already.
We're in trouble already, right?
The great disappointment of 1844.
Now, what had happened is they
had studied. Now, not the Adventists,
they didn't exist.
No.
Let's make this quite plain.
Adventism
evolved out of a great awakening
movement.
And there were two streams in this
awakening.
It was a it was virtually a universal
awakening, but particularly in the
United States, there was what was called
the Great Awakening.
And the one stream was the evangelical
stream, which believed in the temporal
millennium of peace, where all the
nations would be converted, and many
were on board waiting for this
millennium of peace on the earth.
And then there was the other stream,
which was
basically from the Millerite movement,
from William Miller,
who studied the scripture and came to
the conclusion, like many many previous
researchers had found,
that this was not scriptural.
And that there wouldn't be a temporal
millennium of peace where the nations
would be converted. It's almost like a
second chance doctrine, right?
And the scriptures clearly taught
something else. The scripture taught
that Christ would come with power and
great glory,
and that Jesus would come to the earth,
and that the wicked would be destroyed
at that coming.
And there are numerous verses in the
Bible which deal with that. Perhaps you
can post uh
one of the links on
the Bible verses in sequence as to what
happens. Um it's called History's Coming
Climax.
Yes, I'll post that. Post that one.
And then,
the resurrection of the righteous,
the translation of the living righteous,
and together they meet the Lord in the
air. They are taken away.
So, this concept, as opposed to a
concept of a secret rapture and then a
millennium of peace here on earth where
everybody will be converted, etc., etc.,
these two issues were in conflict.
Now, it was based on the study of
Daniel, the 2,300-day
prophecy.
And it has a specific starting date, 457
BC, when the decree went out that
Jerusalem was to be restored. We're not
going to do the Bible study. And when
you work it out, it works out to 1844
when that time period ends.
Yes.
They made a mistake in their calculation
because it went from 457 BC
to AD,
they miscalculated in terms of the zero
Mhm. because you cannot count the zero.
So,
it actually was not 1843, but 1844.
initial date was 1843. Correct, because
they had made a calculation error. And
then,
of course, Christ didn't come.
And they didn't understand
the wording of Daniel. "Then shall the
sanctuary
be cleansed."
And this started a whole investigation.
Now, if you go to Revelation chapter 10,
let's just go there.
Revelation chapter 10.
There's a chapter there about
this mighty angel who comes down from
heaven clothed with a cloud and a
rainbow was upon his head, and his face
were as it were the face of the sun.
It's a description of Jesus standing on
the water and on the land.
And then he has in his hand
a scroll,
but it is sealed. It is closed.
And
a sealed scroll is is something that has
that people have no knowledge about.
They don't know what it means, but it
was to be unsealed. It was to be
understood.
Now, if you study your Bible, you will
find that there's only one prophecy that
was sealed.
Daniel tried to understand what the
prophecy meant, but he was told by the
angel Gabriel
that it is sealed
for the time of the end. So, only then
will it be understood. Go your way, you
will rest, and in the end you will stand
and receive your allotted inheritance.
So, here was a sealed prophecy, and the
time had now come for the unsealing of
the prophecy.
And then this beautiful story in Daniel
in Revelation chapter 10
where
John in vision takes the scroll and eats
it. In other words, internalizes the
message, and it was sweet as honey in
his mouth.
In other words, it was a joyful message.
And the joyful message of the unsealing
of the scroll was Christ is coming
again.
But then it turned bitter, sour in his
stomach. And there was a great
disappointment. They thought the end had
come, but the end had not come, and then
they received the instruction, you must
prophesy again.
And uh
this we read in Revelation chapter 10.
And it says, and I let's read from verse
10. And I took the little book out of
the angel's hand, and I ate it up, and
it was in my mouth sweet as honey. And
as soon as I'd eaten it, my belly was
bitter, bitter disappointment.
And he said unto me, thou must prophesy
again. It's a very important word.
They thought prophesying, preaching had
come to an end,
but they were told no.
Now, you must prophesy again before many
peoples and nations and tongues and
kings. In other words, there is a
universal message that you now have to
bring to the world.
Now, what is that universal message?
Where do we find similar language? We
find it in Revelation chapter 14
where we have the three angels message.
And we read there from verse six in
Revelation chapter 14, and it says, and
I saw another angel fly in the midst of
heaven having the everlasting gospel.
Unchanged.
In other words, the same gospel that has
existed forever.
There is no gospel of dispensation
where
the criteria for salvation change over
time. So, there is no dispensation of
law when you have to be obedient and
grace where you do not have to follow
the commandments.
So, I saw another angel fly in the midst
of heaven having the everlasting gospel,
and we've said it many times. Adam and
Eve were saved by the blood of the lamb.
They had to slaughter the lamb, and
their nakedness was coveredness by
the skins, in other words, the
righteousness, the righteous robe of
Christ.
To preach unto them that dwell on the
earth and to every and there you have
it, nation and kindred and tongue and
people. So, here follows the message,
and it's the three angels messages.
Now,
people say that they had a wrong
interpretation of the Bible.
And this great disappointment points to
the fact that actually their start was a
laughingstock.
It didn't come A false teaching. Didn't
come to fruition.
Now, the question is, of course,
has God made use of disappointments in
the past?
And what was the purpose of the
disappointment?
Well, just go to the crucifixion.
Jesus had taught
on numerous occasions exactly what was
going to happen to him.
But because of their concept
and their understanding
of this kingdom that would be introduced
where the enemies would be dissipated,
it went
over their head, right?
And so,
what happened was when Jesus then was
crucified,
their hopes
were crucified with him.
And here they were
incredibly disappointed.
And we read about those two who were
walking on the way to Emmaus, and the
third one appears amongst their midst.
And they're so dejected. Have you not
heard what has happened? And all their
hopes and dreams are gone.
And then Jesus started from the
beginning and they gave them a Bible
study, and when they finally grasped it
and they knew who he was, they said, did
did not our hearts burn within us?
And they had so much energy
that they ran all the way back to
Jerusalem.
Told the disciples, and they of course
all believed them, right?
No, they didn't believe them. So, this
is a situation. Now, why did God allow
this great disappointment?
Well, it purified the church.
Because only those who
were convinced that they had not been
misled, that there must be something
else
were still part of the movement. So, the
loaves and the fishes
uh adherents were gone. Oh, well,
another false prophecy, right?
He was going to be the one, but now he's
dead.
And so, there was a great disappointment
then, and at the end again, there was a
great disappointment.
Now, who was disappointed?
The people that were involved were from
various denominations.
It was Methodist, largely Methodists and
Baptists. Largely Methodists and
Baptists, minorities on on the
continent.
And then there were Congregationalists,
and they were of all the other
denominations, each one of them with
separate entities of truth.
One little group believed, let's say, in
the state of the dead, that the dead
sleep until the resurrection. Another
group believed another doctrine, and
eventually they
studied the scriptures
and said, what does it mean the
sanctuary will be cleansed? They thought
it was Christ was going to return to
this earth, and the earth is the
sanctuary, and the and the sanctuary was
going to be cleansed from this thing
called sin.
But that's not what it meant.
And then one day
a man by the name of
Edson
Hiram Edson was walking in his field.
That was after the great disappointment.
Correct. They were they were studying
the scripture to see where they'd made a
mistake.
And then
suddenly
he understood.
In a in a in a form of a vision almost
that the sanctuary was the sanctuary in
heaven.
And that it had to be cleansed. And so,
the great sanctuary doctrine
developed. Now, the sanctuary doctrine
is unique to Seventh-day Adventists.
Um just
something that I'd like to mention also
is at that part, Ellen White didn't have
any visions yet.
And she didn't predict the coming of
Jesus in 1844.
So, that's just a misconception on that
also from
The Millerite preachers
from all these different denominations.
There were about 112 of them.
They were the ones that through Bible
study had come to these conclusions.
Adventism evolved out of this great
disappointment. So, the sanctuary
doctrine is basically unique to
Seventh-day Adventists. Now, here's a
here's an interesting question.
If you study the Old Testament, how much
of the Old Testament concerns the
sanctuary?
The whole Old Testament well. Yes. Yeah,
everything. The sanctuary is everywhere.
All the services, the whole the whole
Pentateuch, the five books of the Bible
are about the sanctuary. Leviticus is
about the sanctuary. I mean, the
sanctuary forms a huge part of the Old
Testament.
It's about the sacrifices and all the
Everything that is associated with it.
And the New Testament is just gone.
Now, is there perhaps a major truth
in the sanctuary doctrine?
And the answer is obviously yes, must
be.
If it forms such a great part
of the Old Testament, then surely the
sanctuary must be important. And when
you get to the book of Hebrews, you will
understand how
Paul uses the typology in the Old
Testament
and makes it applicable to the New
Testament. And it's a beautiful study.
The book of Hebrews is a fantastic book.
Let me just go to the book of Hebrews.
And you know what? Chapter 9 is
particularly important when it comes to
the book of Hebrews regarding the
ministry of Jesus Christ.
Now, it says,
"Then verily, the first covenant
had also ordinances of divine service
and a worldly sanctuary." So, here was a
sanctuary on Earth.
"For there was a tabernacle made the
first
wherein was the candlestick and the
table and the showbread which is called
the sanctuary."
So, on the in the earthly sanctuary,
there was a first chamber.
And separating the outer court from the
first chamber, you had a veil.
Then you had this first chamber in which
were the candlesticks
and the table of showbread
and the altar of incense. And then there
was another veil.
And Paul says that this veil represents
his Jesus' flesh
that was torn on our behalf and that's
why the veil tore
when Christ was crucified.
So, there was the first apartment. And
after the second veil,
the tabernacle which is called the
holiest of all.
This is very fascinating because
when we deal with the sanctuary
doctrine,
Adventism gets a lot of flak.
And we need to understand
why this is so important.
The sanctuary, of course, stands for the
plan of salvation. Yes. Now, we've we've
dealt with it in the past, but let's
just briefly go through it again.
If you take the tabernacle that Moses
built which was a pattern
and the temple was later just on a
larger scale, but it had the same
meaning. And everything is so precise.
It's so beautiful.
There are so many messages hidden in it
within the size of all of these things.
So, when you come from outside, from the
world, and you come into the sanctuary,
you came through one opening, one door.
Jesus says, "I am the door."
Immediately, you were surrounded by the
outer wall which consisted of white
linen.
That represents the righteousness of
Christ.
So, when you come to Christ and you
enter into the door, which is Christ,
you're surrounded by his righteousness.
And then you had to bring a lamb if you
were a sinner and we all have sinned and
fall short of the glory of God. And then
you had to sacrifice that little lamb
and the blood
was applied to the horns of the altar
and the sacrifice was burnt on the altar
outside. That represents the cross where
Jesus died on behalf of my sins.
Now, the high the priest that
officiated,
he also represents Jesus Christ.
So,
in type, the priest also had to bring a
sacrifice for himself on a regular
basis.
And because he had taken a small portion
of that lamb when it had been roasted in
the fire, he would put it in his mouth
and he would eat it.
So, in type,
the sins that had been transferred and
confessed over the lamb, the lamb had
died for the sins. In type, that sin was
transferred to the high priest.
In other words, in type, he became a
type of the sin bearer representing
Jesus Christ.
Then when he brought his own sacrifice,
then in type, that sacrifice not only
was a sacrifice for the the high priest
who was a human being's sin,
but also for those that had been
confessed.
And then he would take that blood and he
would carry it into the holy place and
apply it to the horns of the altar.
Now, in in type, that blood
was shed for my sins. So, it is the
record of sins.
So, in other words, all confessed sins
are carried to the holy place and placed
on the horns of the altar. Can we put
that in modern language?
All right, it's not a very good analogy,
but let's use it as an analogy.
Let's say
that
there's a computer
and
all the sins that have been confessed
are on the drive and then you transfer
them to the big server which is inside
the sanctuary and there is a complete
record of all the confessed sins.
So, the record of confessed sins is on
the main server which is the horns of
the altar in the holy place.
And then
the next thing was the labor
which represented the washing of
rebirth.
And then when you went into the veil,
you went again through Christ, you come
into the veil, you're covered by the
righteousness of Christ, there's the
candlestick, there's the showbread,
there's the altar of incense. Jesus
says, "I am the light of the world."
So, the candlestick represents
Jesus, the light of the world.
There are seven candlesticks. The number
seven is, of course, the number of
divinity. We can go into great details.
There are seven churches, Christ the
savior of all ages, etc.
The altar of incense is the
intercession.
Christ my intercessor who pleads on my
behalf.
And the smoke that goes up, Revelation
tells us, is the prayer of the saints
saints
made acceptable to God through the
merits of Jesus Christ. It's a beautiful
story.
The showbread represent There were 12 of
them. Represents Christ,
the unleavened bread, the bread that
came down from heaven, his character,
his life that was shed for me.
And I have to internalize that bread.
In other words, the bread of life.
So, the candlestick, the word, the bread
of life, the character of Christ must be
internalized and I must accept him as my
mediator.
Then the record of sin
had to be at some stage, once a year, be
removed from the sanctuary in type.
So, you went the high priest once a year
into the most holy place.
And in the most holy place, there was
the law.
Inside of the in the ark of the
covenant.
Now, the law is the standard of
judgment. The law actually condemns me
to death.
The law cannot save me.
Only the spotless lamb of God can save
me.
And above the law,
there was a mercy seat. It's a beautiful
name. It's actually a throne
between two cherubim.
And there
God himself sits on his throne, on the
mercy seat. In other words, God shields
me through his mercy from the
condemnation of the law.
It's a beautiful picture.
Now, there were two goats at that stage
that were used in the sacrifice.
There was the Lord's goat and there was
the scapegoat.
And what they did is the high priest
went in
and he made atonement and he sprinkled
the blood of the sacrifice up against
the ark
and he made atonement for the ark. Then
he went out into the holy, he made
atonement for that, then he came out
and he placed his hands up on the
scapegoat
and in type transferred the record of
confessed sins to the scapegoat
who was led into the wilderness and
didn't die. That's what happened. Now,
how
do we apply that?
So, Adventism realized, or the early
Adventists when they studied this,
that
there must have been an event that took
place in heaven.
Where Jesus, as the high priest,
officiating,
went into the most holy
and the process of the cleansing of the
record of sin took place
in the most holy.
And here is a bone of contention. Now,
you know, you have to go actually to
Daniel chapter 7 to see where this all
starts. So, let's go to the book of
Daniel
and let's go to the book of Daniel
chapter seven
and we can read there
from verse
nine.
And it says
I beheld till the thrones were cast down
and the ancient of days did sit.
Whose garment was white as snow and the
hair of his head like the pure wool.
His throne was like the fiery flame and
his wheels as burning fire.
A fiery stream issued and came forth
from before him thousand thousands
ministered unto him and 10,000 * 10,000
stood before him.
And the judgment was set
and the books were opened.
Now, this is a scene that takes place in
heaven.
Here is a heavenly judgment scene. Now,
what's going to happen?
Now, remember
Daniel chapter seven deals with the
kingdoms of the earth and in particular
with the little horn power that the
reformers all identified with the Roman
system, the Roman Catholic system. So,
here's a judgment scene
but it's not on earth, it's in heaven.
And I beheld then because of the voice
of the great words which the horn spake.
So
the system down here
the Roman system, the papal system was
speaking great words.
And I beheld even till the beast was
slain and his body destroyed and given
to the burning flame.
So, he watches the final stages of earth
history. We are now in those stages.
As I
As concerning the rest of the beast,
they had their dominion taken away yet
their lives were prolonged for a season
and a time.
I saw in the night vision and behold one
like the son of man, that's Jesus.
In the King James, it's son with a
capital S.
Came with the clouds of heaven, in other
words, with the angels and came to the
ancient of days. He's coming to the
throne room judgment scene.
And they brought him near before him and
there was given him dominion and glory
and a kingdom
that all people, nations and languages
should serve him. His dominion is an
everlasting dominion which shall not
pass away and his kingdom that which
shall not be destroyed.
And then he receives the vision.
So, this is judgment scene. Now
what happened there? Now, let's go back
to Hebrews chapter nine.
So, there were He describes this
tabernacle, the earthly tabernacle and
he describes the first chamber and then
he describes the second chamber in verse
three and he says and after the second
veil, the tabernacle which is called the
holiest of all
which is the most holy, Hagia Hagion
is the original.
Which had the golden sensor and the ark
of the covenant overlaid around with
gold wherein was the golden pot that had
the manna and Aaron's rod that had
budded and the table of the covenant.
In other words, the ten commandments.
And over at the cherubim of the glory
shadowing the mercy seat
of which we cannot now speak
particularly.
Now, when these things were thus
ordained, the priest went always into
the first tabernacle
according to the service of God.
But into the second went the high priest
alone once every year not without blood.
Which he offered for himself and for the
errors of the people. So, that's what I
explained, right?
So, he in type was the one who had
internalized all the sins, typologically
speaking, representing the great high
priest Jesus Christ who was the real
antitypical, the great fulfillment of
all of these types and shadows.
The Holy Ghost this signifying that the
way of the holiest of all was not yet
made manifest while as the first
tabernacle was yet standing.
So, the first tabernacle, the earthly
one was just a type. This is something
that took place in heaven. Now, it
amazes me that people say
that Adventism talks about the sanctuary
in heaven as though it didn't exist. It
is
it's clear as crystal.
Even
if you read and you understand what that
Moses was shown
the
the real one to make a duplicate of it.
Exactly and he was given exact
measurements. Yeah, he couldn't make
something if he didn't see it from
somewhere. And it is a shadow of the
real thing.
And then it says in verse nine
which was a figure for the time then
present. It was a shadow, it was a type.
Yes.
In which were offered both gifts and
sacrifices that could not make him that
did the service perfect.
So, this whole issue of perfection
that is such a constant bone of
contention with the Adventist uh
critics.
It is clear that the gifts and the
sacrifices, all your works
could not make him that did the service
perfect as pertaining to the conscience.
There was a greater cleansing that was
needed, Christ himself.
Which stood only in meats and drinks and
diverse washings and carnal ordinances
imposed on them until the time of the
reformation.
In other words, until the time of its
fulfillment.
But Christ being come on high priest of
good things to come
by a greater and more perfect
tabernacle. Now, listen to these words
carefully.
Not made with hands, that is to say not
of this building.
How much clearer can you get it? He says
it twice.
He says he's talking about this greater
tabernacle, this heavenly one and then
it says not made with hands, in other
words, heavenly one.
That is to say
a repetition
not of this building. So, it's a
heavenly one.
And then this magnificent verse, verse
12.
Neither by the blood of goats and calves
but by his own blood he entered in once
into the holy place
having obtained eternal redemption for
us.
That's the King James version.
Now, this is where there is a lot of
criticism
regarding this issue.
Many believe
that
the disappointment in
was as a result of a mistaken
theology.
But the prophecy of Daniel is very, very
clear. It ends in 1844.
What happened in 1844?
The only clue we have is the cleansing
of the sanctuary.
Now, the sanctuary, which is now part of
Advent doctrine
must explain to us what happened when
the sanctuary was cleansed.
Well, on the great day of atonement
there was a cleansing of the record of
sin.
It was a day when you afflicted your
soul and you
made every effort to be right with God.
We are living in such a time.
So, in other words, after 1844, we are
living in the antitypical day of
atonement.
So, now here's a question.
And this is a very important question.
Many believe that when Christ died
he went straight into the most holy
place.
Now
that is a problem
because it is contrary to the whole
sanctuary message.
There was an earthly sanctuary and the
priest officiated
for a whole year in the first
tabernacle.
And then on the day of atonement, he
went into the second chamber, right?
Now, when did Christ officiate in the
first tabernacle if he is the high
priest and he is the antitype of this
whole process, then surely he also, if
the type points to the antitype, had to
do service in the holy, in the first
chamber. When did he do it?
Well, if he went into the most holy,
then when did he go into the holy?
Well, some believe that he must have
done that before he came to earth.
Before he was incarnate.
Well, there's a problem with that. Yes.
Let's just read it.
Verse 12 says, "Neither by the blood of
goats and calves,
but by his own blood he entered in once
into the holy place, having obtained
eternal redemption."
Now, if he only entered in with his own
blood, if he only could do service in
the heavenly with his own blood, his own
blood was not available
before he came to this earth. It was
only shed for us
at the cross.
So, he could not have gone into the most
holy. Now, why do the modern
translations
violate this principle? Because it says
here in the King James that he went into
the holy place. It doesn't say it went
into the Hagia Hagion, most holy place,
but the modern translations, even the
New King James version,
change this to read
most holy place.
We can look it up. Shall we look it up?
Yes, why not? Let's put it on the
screen.
I just wanted to ask while you're
looking it up.
I've
If I'm not mistaken, I've heard some
people say, "Okay, when the
veil was torn,
that's the reason, so the most holy and
holy actually became
open to each other."
The only reason why it tore was to show
that the dispensation
of the sanctuary, the earthly, had come
to an end.
And that the wall of separation was now
gone. It's got nothing to do with the
separation between the holy and the most
holy in the in in the heavenly sense.
And
No, that had obviously two chambers
because it was built on the pattern.
Yes.
So, here we have the King James version.
And it says, "Neither by the blood of
goats and calves, but by his own blood
he entered
in once into the holy place, having
obtained eternal redemption for us."
The NIV reads it "He did not enter by
means of the blood of goats and calves,
but he entered the most holy place."
But it doesn't say Hagia Hagion.
Yes.
So, it cannot be the most holy place.
"Once for all by his own blood, thus
obtaining eternal redemption."
If we go to the New King James version,
it reads
"Not with the blood of goats and calves,
but with his own blood he entered the
most holy place."
So,
logically, the King James is the only
one here that renders this of these
three correctly.
So, now, what is Jesus doing in the most
holy place?
That is the next crucial point. What is
he doing
in the most holy place? So,
he went into the holy at his
resurrection.
And then, when did he go into the most
holy?
The only clue we have is Daniel chapter
9.
Where we have
the statement that the sanctuary shall
be cleansed
at the end of the 2,300
day prophecy.
What is he doing? Well, the law is
there, right? Which is the standard of
judgment. And we saw the great judgment
scene taking place. In other words,
Jesus went into the most holy. And
there, the Adventists have coined a
phrase which says, "There the great
pre-advent
judgment takes place."
And this, of course, creates a big can
of worms because people will say that
that is not biblical.
That there is no pre-advent judgment
because all will stand before the
judgment seat of God, etc. So,
this point is very important, this
pre-advent judgment. Now, if I can put
it simply,
when Jesus returns,
does he bring his reward with him?
Yes. Yes. Is there a resurrection of the
just? Yes.
Is there a translation of the righteous?
Yes. Is there a destruction of the
wicked?
Yes.
Okay. So, when Jesus returns, the
righteous dead are raised. The righteous
living are translated.
They, together with them, go and meet
the Lord in the air. The unrighteous are
not resurrected. They are only
resurrected a thousand years later. And
the unrighteous living are destroyed.
Correct?
Yes.
So, there must have been a judgment.
It must have taken place in heaven,
right?
Yes. So, before he was officiating,
and it tells us in Daniel chapter 7 that
books were opened. In other words, a
record of deeds and acts was
investigated.
And a judgment was made. The Bible is
very clear, all judgment has been given
to Christ.
Yes. All judgment. So, he's already
performed the judgment before he comes.
That is called a pre-advent judgment.
Now, what about the saints, where the
Bible says and judgment was handed over
to them?
Yes.
Obviously, if the saints are in heaven
and the others are not in heaven,
judgment has already taken place. So,
what is handed over to him? This is what
I like about God.
He is so incredibly fair.
The record that he based his judgment on
is handed over to the saints cuz books
are open.
Yes. There's the book of life, there's
the book of remembrance, all of these
books, and the whole record is laid open
to God's people.
And they can go through the judgment
and actually verify
that Christ's judgment was fair. Yes.
Because in a sense, Christ is also on
trial because the devil accuses him of
not being fair. Now, the saints can look
and look at the books. So, let's just
talk about this
this judgment that is such a problem.
I have a book here which is just a
little summary of of the issue.
So, this word investigation, I'm not
going to go through the whole thing.
It's not in the Bible. So, people will
say, "But, you know, that word is not in
the Bible, therefore you cannot use it."
But,
the word millennium is not in the Bible
and we use it.
And the word
incarnation is not in the Bible and we
use it. Or virgin birth and we use it.
So, that doesn't seem to be an issue.
And
any judgment has three phases. There's
the investigative stage, where you
investigate the issue.
Then there's the pronouncement of
judgment. And then there is the
execution of judgment, the executive
phase. So, those three phases you must
have. So, before Christ comes to the
earth, there must be an investigation.
Yes.
And then there is a pronouncement of
judgment.
And then he says, "Let them that are
wicked be wicked still. Let them that
are just be just so." It's There's a
pronouncement. And then there is an
executive judgment. He comes and he
executes judgment. Now, let's be
serious. We know there is a judgment.
Mhm. Ecclesiastes 12:13 and 14, Hebrews
9:27
tell us clearly that there is a
judgment.
And this judgment is of all men.
Romans 14:10 tells us this judgment is
of all men.
And there is a judgment of the righteous
and the wicked. Ecclesiastes 3:17. So,
there is a judgment.
There will be an investigation of all
the cases, and we read that in Daniel
7:10.
And Luke chapter 20:33 confirms it. So,
there's going to be a judgment.
And then there's the pronouncement of
the verdict, which you read in
Revelation chapter 22:11
and 12.
And then there is the execution of the
judgment, which we read in Revelation
20:11
to 15.
So, all of those phases are there.
Now, as we've already said, the
righteous are declared worthy.
Now, this word is very interesting.
We find it in Luke chapter 20 verse 35.
And they're worthy to escape all of the
condemnations. Luke 21 verse 36.
And they're worthy of the kingdom of
God. Now, it's interesting this little
word worthy. The Greek word that is used
there doesn't denote that you are made
worthy.
It means that you are counted worthy.
Okay.
That's very important.
Yes.
And uh
Nothing you can do can get you the title
of worthy. Correct. Now, who's the
judge? It's clear. The Bible says that
God is the judge and that all judgment
has been given unto Jesus.
Now, we don't have to go into great
detail, but there's one verse that's
very fascinating. Let's just look it up.
John 5:24.
And it reads as follows.
Now, I'm going to read it first
in the NIV for a particular reason.
Everybody knows my stand on this issue.
Uh
which is so quite disconcerting to some,
but nevertheless
John 5:24
in the NIV reads as follows. Very truly
I tell you, whoever hears my word and
believes him who sent me has eternal
life and will not be judged
but has crossed over from death to life.
So, you do not going to have judgment
upon
um pronounced upon you.
This is a This is a problematic verse
because we've just seen that all
will be judged.
Yes. Everyone. Every single one. And
there are numerous verses and I
mentioned them just now. So, you will
not be judged. In other words, all you
have to do is believe.
Mhm.
And this is not biblical.
Yes, you have to believe.
But if you believe
and if you trust God and if you love
him, then what?
Keep his commandments.
Then we'll keep his commandments. Now,
you know what? This concept
that all you have to do is believe
Mhm.
and then you are saved.
Why is it not biblical? Why were Adam
and Eve removed from the Garden of Eden?
It's because of disobedience.
Are you going to tell me that on the
basis
of believing alone without obedience,
you're going to go back into the into
the garden?
If they were removed from the Garden of
Eden because of disobedience, then
surely
the prerequisite for going back
is obedience.
There's the other problem. Because they
disobeyed, they were subject to death.
Now, Christ paid that price for me
and he covers me with his righteousness.
I have no righteousness of my own.
But obedience remains as much a
prerequisite. Like Revelation chapter 22
tells us that you have the right to the
tree of life if you keep the
commandments. Exactly.
Now, let us just read this same verse
in the revised version.
And it says verily the same thing.
It says verily, verily I say unto you,
he that heareth my word and believeth
him that sent me has eternal life and
cometh not into judgment. So, it's the
same as the NIV.
in him, you won't be judged.
But has passed out of death into life.
Now, let's read the King James version.
And the King James says, verily, verily
I say unto you, he that heareth my word
and believeth on him that sent me hath
everlasting life. Up to there, we're the
same, right?
Yes.
And shall not come into condemnation
but is passed from death unto life.
There's a little difference there. And
the context is in harmony
with uh the rest of scripture.
So, I come into judgment.
But if I have the robe of Christ's
spotless righteousness I won't have
condemnation.
then I do not come into condemnation.
And that is a very very important point.
So, this aspect
of the pre-advent judgment
it's not a complicated issue. It is a
very biblical issue.
There is a judgment and the judgment has
already taken place. So, there is a
pre-advent judgment when Jesus comes.
Now, if my record of sin was in the
sanctuary
then that record is a record of
confessed and forgiven sins through the
intercession of Jesus Christ.
And therefore, I want my sins to be
recorded in the sanctuary. Because if
they're not recorded
Yes.
if I haven't confessed them over the
lamb, they're on my head.
Yes.
And the wages of sin is death. death.
So, I have to believe in Jesus. I have
to believe in his atonement.
So, it is not a false doctrine to
believe in
the sanctuary doctrine. It's a biblical
doctrine. And Jesus went into the holy
after his resurrection because that's
when he had his own blood.
And then sometime thereafter, and the
only time we have in scripture is 1844,
the cleansing of the sanctuary, he went
into the most holy
where the pre-advent judgment takes
place based on the law. Mhm. Which is
the standard of righteousness. It is
beautifully logical. But I don't have to
be afraid of it
because Jesus is my my righteousness.
Now, the other thing that the people say
is that uh
Adventism preaches
legalism.
Mhm.
Now,
and they say you have to keep the
Sabbath.
Yeah. Now, it always amazes me how
keeping the Sabbath can be legal
legalism because the Sabbath symbolizes
rest.
Yes. Rest from what? Rest from works.
So, therefore, the Sabbath is the symbol
of righteousness by faith and not the
the symbol of salvation by works.
So, people criticize Adventism on the
basis of the sanctuary doctrine, which
is biblical as we saw.
Mhm.
It's a beautiful doctrine of the plan of
salvation.
They criticize them on the basis of the
pre-advent judgment which says that the
beautiful promise
that if you are in Christ, you do not
come into condemnation.
But without obedience, nobody will see
God. Yes. Because faith without works is
dead.
Now,
these critics also take statements out
of Ellen G. White
and say that they prove by this that
Adventists believe in salvation by the
law.
And they believe that they can become
sinless and perfect.
Mhm.
And they quote quotes from Ellen G.
White. And some of them might appear as
if they are actually saying that.
But now, let let's get real.
Let's go to the Bible first. Let's talk
about
the Bible says, be ye perfect as your
Father in heaven is perfect.
That's a scary verse.
Yes.
It tells me that I must be as perfect as
my Father in heaven is perfect. Then you
have the counter verse which you find
John in John and he says,
he who says he is without sin is a liar
and the truth is not in him.
Mhm.
So now, two verses. One says I must be
perfect like my Father in heaven is
perfect. The other one says if I say
that I am perfect like my Father in
heaven is perfect, I'm a liar. Mhm.
Uh excuse me.
How do we reconcile those two?
I can do the same with Ellen G. White.
Yes.
I can take all the quotes where she
talks about perfection
and put them in a list
and say that's what Adventism teaches.
Mhm.
But if I don't balance it with the
statements which say that I cannot be
sinless then I have the same impasse as
I have now here with the Bible.
And it's very easy to do.
Yes. Now, how do I reconcile two verses
that are so diametrically opposed to
each other?
in Christ.
Because I can be perfect like my father
in heaven is perfect if I'm covered by
the perfect robe of his righteousness.
Yes.
But that doesn't make me any less sinful
sinful
Yeah. in my nature.
And that is how you reconcile it. And
that is how you must read the spirit of
prophecy.
Now, this debate
doesn't only rage within Adventism, it
raged since the beginning of the world.
There were those who said I'm saved by
my works, Cain. Yes.
And there were those that said, "No, I'm
saved by the sacrificial lamb
that
shed his blood for me."
Abel. Mhm.
This dichotomy has been going on
Mhm. for a long, long time.
If you go to Matthew 24,
the greatest condemnation
that Jesus ever expressed,
"Woe to you."
was against two groups, the scribes and
the Pharisees.
And there the same issue of salvation by
works was a central part. It raged then
and it rages today.
Today, yeah.
Don't say to the public, "This is a war
within Adventism." because it's not
true.
There is a war in Adventism, but it's
not only in Adventism. The same war
waged between Arminian thinking and
Calvinistic thinking. It has come a
long, long way.
My wife
put together a document where she took
the statements from the spirit of
prophecy
to show what the real teaching is and
that it is in perfect harmony
with be ye perfect
and he who says, "I am without sin."
Perhaps we can look at a few of those
quotes. You can. I think that would make
the issue
quite clear. Let's just go there.
We're not going to discuss the whole
document.
Mhm. Just a verse here and there or a
quote here and there. I'll make it
available. Please append it. Yeah. Make
it an appendix so that people can study
it for themselves and see what the issue
is.
Uh
Let's look.
Here's a quote from the Acts of the
Apostles.
True sanctification comes through the
working out of the principles of love.
God is love and he that dwelleth in love
dwelleth in God and God in him. 1 John
4:16.
The character will be purified,
elevated, ennobled, and glorified.
All the reformers taught that.
This is not unique to Ellen G. White.
Uh Wesley taught this.
Those who would gain the blessing of
sanctification must first learn the
meaning of self-sacrifice.
It is the fragrance of our love for our
fellow men that reveals our love for
God.
It is a patience in service that brings
rest to the soul.
These are beautiful
statements. Now, when we talk about
perfection,
she makes a very clear distinction
between perfection and sinlessness.
Remember, be ye perfect as your father
in heaven is perfect and he who says
he's without sin is a liar. And it is so
easy
to quote one section with
out quoting the other one.
She says,
"We must strive daily against outward
evil and inward sin."
If we would reach the perfection of
Christian character, there is a war
going on in our members.
She says it is a constant warfare
against the slavery of passion.
She says, "We must be perfect
Christians, deny ourselves all the way
along tread the narrow, thorny pathway
that our Jesus trod.
And then if we are final overcomers,
heaven's sweet will be cheap enough."
Here's the emphasis on the perfection.
But she qualifies it. Yeah.
None need fail of attaining in his
sphere
the perfection of Christian character.
So, she makes a distinction between in
our sphere
and in God's sphere. Mhm.
And God's sphere is as much higher than
our sphere as God is higher than
humanity. It's as simple as that.
But I must make an effort. Yeah. If I
have a mean disposition,
I must ask God, "Cleanse me from this
mean disposition." Paul says he
crucifies the old man daily. Absolutely.
Absolutely. And that old man is so
stubborn.
How do you achieve it?
Through cooperation with divinity.
That's how you achieve it.
He says in Second Selected Messages,
"And while we cannot claim perfection of
the flesh,
that's important.
That's a real clearer statement.
We may have Christian perfection of the
soul through the sacrifice made in our
behalf.
Sins may be perfectly forgiven." Isn't
that magnificent?
Yeah.
So, my perfection rests upon a perfect
forgiveness, not upon my perfection.
That is presumption.
Our dependence is not in what man can
do, it is in what God can do for man
through Christ.
Through faith in his blood, all may be
made perfect in Christ Jesus. Thank God
that we are not dealing with
impossibilities.
We may claim sanctification. We may
enjoy the favor of God. We are not to be
anxious about what Christ in God thinks
of us,
but about what God thinks of Christ our
substitute. Now, surely this takes away
the fear of the pre-advent judgment.
The pre-advent judgment is not as it is
portrayed out there in the world, a
guillotine that is just waiting to chop
off your head. Haha, I caught you, it's
in the book of record. No.
It says, "Covered by my blood."
And his imperfection is covered by my
perfect righteousness.
That is good news.
Yes.
In other words, you do not come into
condemnation,
but you surely come into judgment.
Now, but judgment is actually good news.
Absolutely.
Absolutely. Christ my intercessor
interceding on my behalf, is that not
good news? Of course.
And that's the way you can
get to heaven. Without that, there's no
way. Now, now take an earthly third
tribunal.
You sit in fear and trembling of the
judge who's going to come out and
condemn you. This judge has never made a
mistake.
Mhm.
And then the beautiful thing is he's
also my advocate.
He is my advocate. Where on earth can I
have a judge who's also my advocate? And
an advocate who has never lost a case.
The judgment is good news, it's nothing
to be afraid of. Thank God
I have a judge, but Mhm.
my sins have to precede me into the
sanctuary.
In other words, Peter said when they
said, "What must we do to be saved?"
His first words were Repent.
Repent.
Yes. What does it mean to repent?
Acknowledge the
Turn around.
Go the other way. So, I've been on a
path of perdition, turn around
Go the other way.
And go and sin no more. Mhm.
That is a true biblical doctrine.
Here's another statement
from the Acts of the Apostles.
John did not teach that salvation was to
be earned by obedience,
but that obedience was the fruit of
faith and love.
If we abide in Christ, if the love of
God dwells in the heart, our feelings,
our thoughts, our actions will be in
harmony with the will of God.
The sanctified heart is in harmony with
the perfect law of God. But then she
qualified it, in my sphere, within my
capability.
Now, when it comes to sinless,
there's another story. So, when it comes
to perfection, she says, "Yes, we can be
perfect." But she qualified it.
Through the robe of Christ's
righteousness, right? Let's have a look
at sinlessness.
God could have proclaimed his truth
through sinless angels.
Angels are sinless.
Heavenly angels, not fallen angels.
And Jesus, he the sinless one, was
treated as we deserve. That we fallen
and sinful might be treated as he
deserved.
Jesus is sinless.
He refers us to him as
the sinless one, the perfect one. He led
a sinless life.
Before the fall, Adam were
Adam and Eve were sinless. That's the
only time.
Again, from the the book The Acts of the
Apostles,
let those who feel inclined to make a
high profession of holiness
look into the mirror of God's law.
As they see its far-reaching claims and
understand its work as a discerner of
the thoughts and intents of the heart,
they will not boast of sinlessness.
If we say, says John, not separating
himself from his brethren,
say that we have no sin, we deceive
ourselves and the truth is not in us. If
we say that we have not sinned, we make
him a liar and his word is not in us. If
we confess our sins,
he is faithful and just to forgive us
our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness.
She says, "Not a soul of you has holy
flesh now. No human being on the earth
has
holy flesh. It is an impossibility."
It's pretty clear. Yes. But she gets
even stronger. How long will I have this
nature?
So long as Satan reigns, we shall have
self to subdue.
Besetting sins to overcome, so long as
life shall last, there will be no
stopping place, no point where we can
reach and say, "I have fully attained."
You know, we have people in the world
that say that they are holy and sinless.
Sanctification is the result of lifelong
obedience. She goes so far as to say,
"Perfection
exists only in our imagination."
Can you see how you can quote the texts
and distort her writings?
People
are always amazing me how they deal with
these issues.
She wrote to one brother
who claimed that he had now finally
reached the sinless state.
And I must quote this one. It is a
beautiful statement.
She says, "Some of them have even
reached the almost hopeless position
that they cannot sin.
These, of course, have no further use of
the Lord's prayer,
which teaches us to pray that our sins
may be forgiven, and but very little use
for the Bible,
as they profess to be led by the spirit.
What a terrible deception. They think
they are complete in Christ and know not
that they are wretched, blind,
miserable, poor, and naked." That puts
it beyond the shadow of doubt.
I can use her writings
to give such a distorted view
that it would appear as if Adventism
teaches
Christian perfection through perfect
obedience to the law. That's legalism.
Yes, and that's that's the
picture that the world has of Adventism.
Absolutely.
we say that
you have to keep the law to be saved.
Correct?
And as but in fact,
that's totally misconception of what
Adventism says. So let's let's just
repeat this again.
Can I be saved by my obedience to the
law? No. Can I be saved in my
disobedience, by willful disobedience of
the law? No. No.
So there's a coin.
There's a one side of the coin and
there's the other side of the coin. And
that is why you have to reconcile Paul
and James.
Yes.
And Martin Luther, when he discovered
the great doctrine of justification by
faith, he was so overwhelmed
because remember, he came from
Catholicism. I came from Catholicism,
too.
And Martin Luther used to chastise
himself.
He used to whip himself.
He used to whip himself repeatedly. And
to this day,
they whip themselves. Do you know that
John Paul II
regularly whipped himself? This is John
common knowledge. It's it's a terrible
thought.
So this concept, I I have to pay for my
sins. This is where purgatory comes in.
I pay for my sins. I am the one
and not Jesus who paid for my sins. In
other words, they deny the atonement.
And here you have this this concept in
Martin Luther
as a Catholic that he has to pay for his
sins. And he discovers righteousness by
faith.
And it's like a weight falls off his
shoulders.
And I can understand that. He was so
overwhelmed with the beauty of the
gospel of salvation.
It is the righteousness of Christ that
saves me.
And he called it an alien righteousness.
He said, "It's not a righteousness that
I have of myself. It is an alien
righteousness, one that comes from
outside of me. It is the beautiful
righteousness of the of Christ that
covers me."
And then he read in the book of James
that faith without works is dead. Yes.
"Show me your faith without your works
and I will show you my faith by my
works," says James. And Martin Luther
says, "This book doesn't belong in the
Bible."
He called it an epistle of straw.
Mhm. But he translated it. Yeah. But he
didn't like it. It didn't fit into his
newly discovered beautiful truth of
righteousness by faith.
And he actually said to his students,
"Here is my doctor's hat." You know, in
the old days they wore the little funny
little doctor's hat.
And he took the doctor's hat and he put
it on the table.
And he said, "Anybody who reconciles
Paul and James
can put that hat on his head. They will
get a doctorate, right?" Yeah. And there
it lay.
Nobody took it. It lay there for I don't
know how long.
And one day Martin Luther walked back
into the class. He picked up his
doctor's hat and he put it on his head.
So what had he done?
He reconciled it. He reconciled it. He
thought it through, the dichotomy.
And the dichotomy is simple. I'm not
saved by my works,
but my works are a consequence of me
being saved.
Yes.
Because I love God, I come back into
harmony. Now, if Martin Luther
reconciled it,
then so must I.
And so must you.
And that is Adventism.
So I think we only came through the
sanctuary doctrine. It's biblical. Yes.
Would you agree? Definitely. There is a
sanctuary
There is a sanctuary in heaven?
There is a first chamber and a second
chamber?
Christ could only enter in with his own
blood?
Yes.
So when he had his own blood, which
chamber did he go into? The holy. The
holy. At some stage later, he must have
gone into The most holy. Is there a
judgment scene described in heaven where
the judgment begins and the books are
being opened? Yes. A pre-advent
judgment, which takes place in heaven,
because he came to the Ancient of Days,
not to the earth.
Yes.
And then, what happens then? When that
judgment is over? He comes back with his
execution.
With his executive judgment. And then he
answered to the saints for verification,
to show that he was fair.
And is it good news or bad news, this
judgment? It's good news. Why? Because
it can set you free and you can go to
heaven.
Absolutely.
And why can you be set free? What is the
condition? What did Peter say? What was
the condition? When they said, "What
must we do to be saved?" What did he
say?
Repent. Ah. And Be baptized.
Be baptized for the washing away of your
sins.
Sins, yes.
It's an amazing doctrine.
And how many people accepted the
invitation on that day?
3,000. 3,000.
3,000 accepted that invitation on that
day.
Washing away your sins. What is a sin?
Transgression of the law.
Transgression of the law. The law is the
standard. Who covers me for my
unrighteousness?
Jesus. It's such a beautiful liberating
doctrine. I wish everybody would embrace
it.
And God takes our weaknesses into
account. Yes, he knows that within your
sphere
this is the level of the bar that you
can reach.
Now, the bar
is so high
that I can never reach it. Yes. But, he
can reach it.
Now, there's two things he could do.
He could lower the bar.
Mhm.
And say, "Okay, now you can jump over
it."
Did he do that?
No. No, because you cannot lower the
standard.
So, he couldn't take away the law at his
crucifixion.
Do not think that I've come to abolish
the law. No, the law stands.
It's so high, I cannot reach it.
But, he can reach it.
And he can pull me
to that level by covering me with his
righteousness.
So, all of these criticisms that we've
spoken about, we only managed to get as
far as the sanctuary. But, we'll get to
the other ones.
We'll get to the other ones as we go on.
So, have you got a closing word for our
listeners? Well, I'm encouraged to know
that
with Christ as my righteousness
I can actually
have a chance at heaven. Absolutely. I
mean
You do not come into condemnation.
Nation. Nation. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, thank you for
the news of the judgment, which is good
news.
Thank you, Lord, that we are not left to
our own weaknesses and own devices, but
that you cover us with your
righteousness.
And that you have promised that if we
forsake our sins and confess our sins,
we do not come into condemnation.
But, through faith in the perfect
offering of our Lord and Savior, we can
stand before the God of heaven in
absolute perfection.
Not our perfection
but his perfection. Thank you for these
promises in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
Thank you for watching this video.
To subscribe, click here. When the bell
appears, click and you will receive
notifications. To watch the next one,
click here.
Thank you again, and see you next time.